hello and welcome to our Monday night
so help you are all alright yeah let's
see who's in the church you've got a
couple of regulars already in there I'm
going to start a five-minute game in the
pool right away
so yeah how is everybody
here from Germany you're suffering the
same same heat wave problem today it was
absolutely amazing here like 34 35
degrees so 26 degrees at the moment
Celsius that is at it so long story okay
so good the first game against Michelle
and I'm going Knight f3 um nope
I don't have a thing going so let's see
what we get against this opponent
probably whom this transposition to to a
more on the open position it's a lot
like the coral can pan off yeah how is
this plate we should be five forms of g5
there are couple of lines I think I'm
going Bishop b5 it doesn't doesn't
really care it seems that I might damage
his pawn structure this is maybe only
this is too technical but yeah we'll see
yeah he really doesn't mind that I take
care well black is getting a little bit
appeal of course but so I'm quite happy
with this with this kind of position
here I do read this Chad yes I
absolutely do it's not a guarantee that
I'm
responding to absolutely everything
because you sometimes I mean you have to
play the game also and sometimes it just
under start looking at at this precise
moment yeah that's the line that I've
played against autographs with the black
pieces a couple of times so it's
something that I have in my repertoire
with both colors so let's see what
Michelle is doing but it says the real
name of this person because a group off
okay yeah I played against them quite
quite a bit so we'll see if he goes
Bishop to f8 I think I'll just go to c3
yes - Bob sedusa says that I don't have
a donation page on my website or I have
not linked the interview yet that I did
for petrol transport car that's true
added that has not I've been done yet
I'm a bit surprised that my opponent
simply gives me this I mean I understand
that Bishop d7 and Queen c6 and so on is
an idea but I still feel that looks it
looks pretty dangerous to give me this
Bishop on f6 so Queen age three is going
I'm wait is that the right way to do it
walking g3 rather like one two I can one
two three four one two three
h5 Cruijff ooh yeah I think I'm going
this way
yeah I want to do those things that was
mentioned by buffs a doozy but didn't
didn't get around to doing it
okay so he wants to sacrifice the
exchange on f6 or at least has this
option yeah he six looks somewhat
tempting yeah I think I do this
just to be ready to take on
I mean I'm threatening to take on f7 so
he probably has to take a 6 and B 54
then I will get the bishop to c3 on that
long diagonal and I'm on c3 I'm
relatively safe from any really what
this is made next move
humming reading what the heck is that
let me know so don't want any regular
match requests a need to take on e6 and
then bishops it should be four should be
quite good for me I think but anyway I'm
glad to have won the first game
yeah suggesting our openings is an idea
and actually I will play some of them
but and we'll see it Sicilian dragon
yeah just to say and dragon I kind of
understand that you find it entertaining
but I will probably get checkmated quite
a bit yeah I've got a request for a game
out but it has not yet materialized
learning a dutch game stole it my god
okay yeah Mitali oh so we've got them
yes she going Queen's Gambit chigorin
yeah I'm just playing a very simple way
it's probably not exactly the way to
refute this opening but it's not easy
anyway so just specially to stopping
they're stopping the pin
okay 98 seems he wants to go to East six
okay yeah 33 sellers it's even hotter
here was mentioned in the chat what the
temperature is like I think Bioshock
writer didn't um dad didn't listen to my
opening words amazing really amazingly
hard okay so what to do a 3d form yeah
you one doesn't really do much I want
like just a three years right you know
that okay I'm not entirely sure what so
I might want to have c6 on the board so
now maybe could be three making it a bit
more difficult for him to move the
knight of course you can play with the
am one of the possible moves
okay so can take on f3 play 92 is this
could be an option and 5 not so much hmm
okay let's let's do this first and then
see what he's coming up with and f5 is
just a bad move for the side of all
bowed should just weaken his structure
on a lot why is that a good move
okay I go g3 first so 95 95 93
unfortunately
I'll do something funky the Queen trade
it doesn't trade the quids okay yeah
thanks for the good feedback on my
record games I'm happy that let you like
them
okay so um what's going on here actually
there is 97 95 93
let's not dissemble at the end always
hmm it's not it's not that great
strangely enough I mean the whole horse
who black syrup looks weird to new it
there should be 297 that was my line I
mean maybe it is completely completely
terrible I thought that this would be
good for me yeah I mean not good as in
winning but I thought I would be fine
him maybe not so much I will always get
out there why such rustic measures yeah
I have wasted too much time the egg felt
I should do something
oh oh that's not good
yeah I should have I should have put put
the night bank earlier okay this is this
is probably okay and he cannot really go
96 now and this is a good ending I mean
again not better but it is good the
other before be five plant seems a
little bit on the slow side that's why I
didn't do it
no little bit behind with pics with the
time but the position is okay I've got a
protected pass only five this is a huge
huge asset in descending many M
transpositions for example into our and
to working upon ending will be winning
plan won't be winning for me
so Katie can can take only five it's an
interesting move a tip here now you have
to move with this kind of situation
don't have the time to figure it out
completely
I have to double-check that's too bad
add from the equal go what's happening
here okay I forgot about the bloody
deform it was completely unnecessary to
get there okay check check
games wrong hmm no don't know that it
was good I should have I think one
descending I mean I shouldn't be in
trouble at least anyway so next game
next game when is the next I will um and
probably middle of June I think
seventeenth problem but it's not
completely same story six today
so FA pal arm
opponent and he's trying probably see
3sl dunno a form I keep forgetting this
I mean I can go before but I'm not sure
this is really right yeah I think this
is correct
aha go see for immediately here okay
taking is probably not a great idea you
can just play the closed position of
course just like this me ID 65 stuff
that's a bit difficult in then I don't
have to this is also not bad just
developing everything an elbow is six I
can still play I can still play e5 I
think I could be five because after okay
one now having the closed structures
actually be more favorable for me then
usual okay I'll think I'll start with
Bishop c8 the bishop on b7 does not make
any sense at all
now preparing f5
I'm not quite sure how I should play a
five which particular way you like this
well and now f5 is on if you take this e
form winning a piece now okay so here I
could take or play Knight f6
let's go Knight f6 that looks a little
bit a little bit off
you can play a four then G for my light
is trapped that's a little bit include
Badham so what to do maybe let me just
double on their file
I don't know it takes interesting but I
can just recapture with the pawn let's
do it
I mean we cannot go f4 now and this just
as I say it plays it why is that a move
why is that a move don't get it don't
get it okay
this is something hanging on that I
don't see em what is the problem here I
don't see it really is just completely
collapsing one two three I think I think
at least let's do this if he takes here
then group takes g2 all I think their
form in both works and he cannot really
covers g3
okay okay
my f4 is the big Fork
check wait
resigned okay I think that looked okay
and there's some discussion in the in
the chat about other chest streamers um
and and there's some discussion about
chest network not playing other
streamers it is an old old story never
plays other other chair streamers and I
never really understood why to be honest
cause um jelly is a really good blitz
player I mean it's not like it wouldn't
be competitive absolutely not yeah I
mean he's not lower rated then then then
I am on some other some other streamers
but he's a really good little a I mean I
had the huge surplus go against him in
bits on the ICC but he has very high
ratings so it's it's not like he would
get totally smashed I mean absolutely
not so um I never quite got why he or he
doesn't do it in fact he doesn't even
answer any messages I mean you can
message him with whatever you never
responded
anyway let's get going I've got a
request out game okay how many 1957 but
some high rated opponents him let's see
okay which one's supposed to an open
Sicilian I can play the accelerated
dragon
and so is that by the way there is no
info so got the main line accelerated
dragon I have the odd idea here let's
see what my opponent is doing taking is
actually uncommon but it's a it's a pre
move that makes sense
usually they exactly and drop it back
yeah this is a fairly decent idea yeah
this is the the simple approach that
I've played against this set up myself
yeah I think this leads absolutely
nowhere
why doesn't even have a hint of an
advantage at least that's what I think
it doesn't it does no it does not have
to be the correct assessment but I'm
reasonably sure okay so I of course I'd
like to go at five okay it's hard to not
play at five
yeah Bishop t1 t2 is an idea for Wyatt
you're right Marcus okay so what is
right up to
I don't like to play with the DAT and
special
what can try to advance a three before
slowly g5 we can take and play 95 check
this is quite irritating I think I go
gb6 I'm and I'm here the groups this
yeah that was suggest I should stream on
Twitch the thing is um of course I could
do that but I rather do a couple of
things with some kind of dedication than
all kinds of things when you don't
really when you cannot do them well and
I don't I don't feel I can I can
steadily do stuff on Twitch simply a
lack of time how and it makes sense
actually what is doing here okay you
have to take this now switch over here
I don't think that without the
discussion about is Grand Master Yoshi
chic where sometimes play I mean the
thing is in over the board chess he does
not play like this because he cannot
afford the unplayable openings that he
that he plays in blitz but in inlets you
can do it it's complicated it's it's
tricky but in you know ver the board
that doesn't that doesn't work on
similarly well this is actually not a
boring position it's a rather difficult
to play ending when I play that well I
don't like to trade so much and Bishop
c2 coming is is an extremely annoying
idea maybe this one
I mean I don't want to play a force
stuff really don't
also just Bishop a4 is a decent move
trying to trade down not good
nicely played out like any really nicely
in this game not good disposition
not sure if I'm lost already but it
looks bad and I've got a time
disadvantage time warning check and it's
just about in time to go there
not very nicely pledged up really nicely
played
trying for some trickery here Wow
yeah let's meter c7s make
I can take a still checkmate
mara can't even Ong three now there is
no trickery
I felt that endru Tang I think it's one
of those pretty strong Buddhist famous
writer guys then it was bad he really
outplayed me
I wonder what I did wrong them probably
I shouldn't trade the rupiah and and
probably g5 you can question
and now g5 is probably a bad idea
interesting I don't think that this
ending is all that great I mean I think
equal issue I think this is maybe
slightly better for why but it's not it
shouldn't be all that much but g5 is
probably wrong I just I should just stay
there I've had this on the board a
couple of times in blitz and usually did
a decent job
okay I've got a request out but not yet
the new game yeah
what's going on here not so much going
on you look well your shake does seem to
be on game stone it we trade our hair -
it's a frequent opponent in my games I
want to try something else
just just for fun play the Jew bomber
variation ones in a six yeah it's one of
the better lines and c5 but oh well I
don't mind that that's what you want in
this opening game lots of space and time
I don't know this is good I'm a not
gaining lots of lots of space here hmm
okay so what to do Queen d2 who all or
something else like clicking and
checking on the tools is also
interesting the act completely clocks
out his development
you cannot play Queen e7 and whatever it
puts on e7 the other piece cannot move
so got this and now I can push it to h3
maybe I should have done that even
before canceling right yeah this is a
good line actually the job on one light
Knight c3 Bishop f4
that it's kind of okay really
you can play that there's nothing
nothing wrong with it
okay so thinking night and now ready for
g6 black night cannot caption and f6 26
something you also don't want to see a
oh really
that looks dangerous dangerous
yeah it's check and now it's a way is it
not going to go to f5 probably it's
quite funny that well 9s fine I can't
click on this 5
look to e1 over you can take h3
Knight f4 to e6 would be cool but Bishop
g3 goes Knight f5 but isn't all that
easy
I would really love to love to do
something else night at 5:00 but I don't
see it okay
I have to play move now just to too long
otherwise I mean if you move the night I
can take the fire so this is not a huge
issue for 95 oh did I did a trap my own
queen here that's funky my queen is no
script
ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha ha what a joke
it says completely crazy what an idiotic
three Queen travel I didn't I didn't see
that one that's funny
from that position I still think that
that was pretty terrible who black
anyway let's let's him let's see yeah ok
let's see where he goes up he can
probably just take the Queen 97 and then
2696 or something nobody moves the Queen
this is what I expected also and yeah
Bishop h6 I looked at this but I don't
think it worked but it suggested in in
the chat so a queen is attacked and I
cannot even get two pieces for it is the
thing if I could get two pieces would
actually be somewhat would have some
some some some faint hope at least but
we'll see I mean at least you cannot
move the light for the area but b6 is
probably winning pretty easily
mouki six actually traps his queen but
he would get so much so much share and
so much material I didn't doesn't work I
would have bet that was funny
hey I let that tradition must have been
completely lost
anyway let's let's see what he does I
mean he played really quite badly before
you never know what is going to do might
play some some bad news as long as I
have the pawn f7 I will not resign of
course not
now I can take then on yourself
now that that's getting slightly
slightly more interesting now it's still
completely lost
is it lost wait wait wait wait it it's
not so easy I'm attacking c7 now and
okay
it's got c4 more time warning also play
whooped e7
it's got Quincy formats extremely lucky
and yes he's lost technically speaking I
will see him maybe I shouldn't have done
that because that is too easy
he really does a lot to make it somewhat
interesting and it's still not
interesting I am probably I should have
done it differently okay okay yeah I was
bad and play recently okay so a new game
losing that one was pretty awful
after getting like this is a completely
winning position yeah that's that's
impossible for black cast what is what
to CN you get a plus two roughly where
this isn't this isn't that clear it
really isn't that clear you can actually
argue g6 is correct
probably it is but clean e6 is actually
not that great because once I get to f7
I have no squares the engine gives this
move and this is basically winning yeah
so I want to get in game still it
against Jason T I know I need to win I
want to get back to to five maybe get
some nice autopilot bank on gambit
people start to play this attack quicker
you still get the odd Bishop d3 which
loses basic lick but it's still somewhat
tricky in blitz yes is the normally here
congrats to like partridge volume ones
Club Championships after seven years it
sounds good
that's a very very weird
Banco gambit so now I can take here then
is doing the King logon it's a quite
remarkable can I go here wow that's a
very strange position with the key now
here there are tactics all over the
place like here 96
let's go 96 threatening Queen c4 check
at night before
if he moves to c3 Knight I'll take a
form it's quite a tricky position
kim ji-won mmmm
and that makes cruces make some sense
reading okay so go here 95 again I take
a form maybe if I you know if I this
yeah yeah yeah let that move that I
should have considered more closely of
course Knight g4 95
[Music]
I know that looks very strange but I
think um I think that that could be an
idea I know it looks very strange right
now I have roopd two bishops III and
night before I think I might win both
pawns which gives me three pawns I know
it looks weird but yes all night before
was my idea and I got 94 actually it's
got night to use form it's not good
that's not good yeah I can take this
bloody thing this is not enough really
not ah not good I can still fight but
that was not good em yeah okay no that's
an ambitious move maybe it's a good move
but it's also quite ambitious so to do I
mean the a porn is not going anywhere
why did he do that
why did he do that
[Music]
it's still not easy for him to untangle
this stuff really not easy because I go
see three
that's an interesting but I can go here
yeah 493 as well
Knight to c6 yes I'm not so happy with
this move to be honest I can check me
and play Bishop to before
okay I cannot cover seven just doesn't
work okay now I can actually move this
now I can actually move it might be
either something if I take you I will
take a five but I don't like this all
that much it's got a really really
strong long diagonal then you I can be
be a pain with this move that you can
just click a shifty form not good not so
much
is playing this quite well actually
pretty good game I'm now calling it
really it was a very tough position to
play and he did a good job okay so not
entirely easy okay okay
yes I cannot cover the bloody thing oh
my god that's terrible
ah check check check
[Music]
one four six one time I was pretty bad
and he did a good job there I really
wanted like I mean I thought I really
was out of the woods but he played good
played well yeah game started okay tough
session at the end I had a good start
but then kind of fell apart in so beyond
let's get going
and somewhere black all the time turn
yeah what did I do wrong about the wind
is thank you I looked I overlooked it
five right because the opening with a QR
f1 that that wasn't it wasn't it wasn't
all that great I cannot believe it
okay so
this is I have on the board really
really often whoa
- okay
who Chad do you five is hanging but I
don't think I can take it
not really happy about this I don't know
what medium you're referring to Ben I
can take the five yeah this is just a
very boring position I'd like to play
this I mean like it's a little bit
strong but it gives a little bit more
more fight into the game the bloomenfeld
gambit room I don't think it is so bad
happen and I have played this in
tournament chess the Blumenfeld
and it didn't turn out to be so bad it's
just that it's not quite clear that
they'll let black an equalized of course
there's some line that us they're
critical but it's not so bad in a
practical game you can always play that
I would have my doubts of here like what
to play every single game but like once
in the world it's perfectly okay Han
yeah and he's going to play look you won
[Music]
yeah what's going on here
can I not just play a sexy and kicking
back 97 Luke a7 that cannot work help be
strange at least it just has to go back
I think or is he going for Sun Bishop f6
some tactic mm interesting
- a3 that's a weird weird position of
that night 92 a3 a5 okay okay yeah let
make some sense of course so let's do
this if he takes it that night is
covering everything nicely and I mean I
have two pieces that that actually can
attack his his pawns oh okay Oh Bishop
f6 ha ha ha ha
no no this is this is just so annoying
okay
oh my god of course I immediately
spotted what I did but I just
aha No
and it's nice that someone has faith in
me but this position sucks big time it's
sucks big time yeah I couldn't really
avoid the Queen trade I mean
now you can go to F forward night h4 and
bring the King around I don't know I
don't think this is so terrible a quick
anomaly I can really just wait hey
someone wants to gank buildings and
Queens gambit declines
I can't play this kind of stuff and
probably won't lose so many games well
then I never thought it is such a such a
great idea to play on a chess channel
Queen a forum I don't know
yeah I just I mean I don't need to
download my pawn should be doubled if I
want that I think I'm kind of okay
anyway let's see I don't think he
accomplished all that much
yeah match against errick henlon or Emil
Hamilton hmm I mean Eric is probably
just killing me and I thought no a man
humbled is also pretty good blitz player
I think I recovered here quite quite
quite nicely what's going on here he's
playing this really strange very strange
fashion okay so can I get to the pawns I
can't get to the pawns right here and it
doesn't do much let's go back and now
see what he's doing
I can now advance this actually and now
how do I tell you I win this h2 it goes
there and I pick up c4 okay time morning
check okay I'm kind of stumped at
winning this ending that was really
really bad wait vision it's a bit
strange that I was winning okay but I
don't I don't know why can I'll tell you
can't tell you okay I'm going to play
one more game
so let's see yeah well I won't get to
form again but a quick quick game would
be nice game story plink pickoffs
I usually go see for you actually it's
okay it's probably not a big deal this
might look a lot like a rule or pass
quickly looks a lot like a we actually
okay and 595 is probably something you
want to avoid but now you can go f5 of
course and so how do you play this one
way to do it is to take play Knight h4
and platform that's a good question if I
have purchased any chess books recently
and I I actually have and I will oh I
think I'll take and then we'll actually
do book reviews some book reviews on my
channel this is pretty clear that I will
do it but it will so take a bit of time
probably in roughly in roughly two weeks
it takes a little time because I will be
at the German Junior Championships as a
coach and and this is I will be away
simply and cannot do all that much so I
think in 90s
yeah g5 was a little bit weird
difficult position my pawn on d5 is a
little bit isolated yeah it's not all
that clear the night is just an
extremely between the annoying piece on
the forum
yeah f1 seems wrong
without the bishop but this is a bit of
a strange position sometimes black and
place e6 I personally will just keep the
tension don't play g5 and everything
just here just keep the tension castles
King age 7 h5 this kind of things
yeah the e4 Knight is awesome Steiner
says but you know it's it's nice but how
exactly what exactly are you doing with
it this is the thing it's not not so
easy
yeah do I want to trade this I'm not
really sure
look c3 is an interesting new Philip
maybe the interesting I mean a7 hangs
and yeah my L account project is
progressing slowly all those things
progress slowly if you do all kinds of
things at the same time things take a
while yeah this is something that I had
anticipated actually and I didn't think
it was all that great and it may be he's
got Luke c4 interesting know where they
form a four would take C form and now I
get c4 in I also have a check on f6 I
also have this get the system in the
bathroom like as I played it myself I
mean it's not it's not completely
rubbish or anything and now I will take
it now then d5 is actually hanging what
the heck okay so will be one
[Music]
takes it will be seven should be should
be good for white I don't don't really
see something good okay so take cm it
what takes you for I can do this and
take b6 next movie
yeah take it it's the coach f5 I guess I
don't know if I I can even go g4 in this
position
oh that doesn't look like it should
survive look C 496 and any other move
apply C 566 and that's that's currents
if we cannot take this I don't really
think you can play the position anymore
so c6 one something technical c6 is a
good move
I came this one and now see seven and
the ages black resumes okay I'm happy
with this game looked like a good
controlled victory for the most part
okay I hope you enjoyed the show what I
have to tell you is that I will not have
a show next week again yeah it's a bit
of a rocky and get a little bit sketchy
at the moment next Monday I will be at
the German Junior Championships in the
villian in Indo Island you know someone
on Germany okay well we have the German
team which is there if you are in
Germany and you have the opportunity to
go there watch the championships or
something that I can definitely
recommend to you it's a great event
absolutely and if you are interested in
a German broadcast by the way of that
championships you can google it there
will be an official livestream of the
German Junior Championships on the site
of the German youth Chess Federation and
I will actually do commentary on three
rounds live from the from the venue in
German language though so if you want to
want to watch some of the top German
juniors and be trying to make heads or
tails of what they play you can go on
that website and see where it leads you
I think I will do the not quite sure I
will do the final round at least that's
what I know okay I hope you have enjoyed
the show and maybe join me for the
coverage next weekend of the tournament
I mentioned bye bye guys
you
you